I don't remember how many people there are I've
been on the battlefield since I was about Mutsu I used
to be a warrior Once upon a
time
in the village where I lived,
soldiers came twice
They wore human skins
Beasts
this time
we must protect our children from the storm of men
Everywhere there are those who like discrimination but there are those who do
n't Don't be
discouraged, both of you
I'm going to England I'm
sure in the near future
Can't you just spend your whole life in this kind of land field?
I have a friend's son who became a slave
You just have to memorize them one by one
[music]
If it's empty, anything goes in If you're
going to be reborn, it
's better to
be empty Look at that trophy Your body is
alive  I'm telling you I
want to go What are you going to do with
[music
]?